emoción es lo que sienten muchos
británicos a la espera de la coronación
del Rey Carlos III en el caso de
margaret Tyler la fascinación por la
familia real comenzó de niña cuando
recortaba fotos de Carlos III y su
hermana Ana una afición que la llevó a
llenar su casa de este tipo de
decoraciones hay quien fuma hay quien
bebe quien se va de vacaciones yo no
hago nada de eso estoy acá viendo la
realeza y que ha hecho que espere este
momento con muchas expectativas ya que
recuerda el Rey Carlos desde que era un
niño tiene una mirada bonita no crees
que sí creo que está pensando oh Dios en
que me he metido
pero los británicos no son los únicos
que esperan este momento con emoción y
vamos para allá estoy tan emocionada
para una webber estadounidense de 71
años y fervientes seguidora de la
realeza británica Esta es una ocasión
muy especial tras varias bodas y varios
jubileos tiene la oportunidad de asistir
a una coronación por primera vez
nadie lo hace como los británicos la
pompa y la circunstancias no tenemos
nada parecido en Estados Unidos
como muchos otros fans de la corona
Weber voló desde Connecticut Estados
Unidos a Londres solo para estar
presente durante la ocasión la primera
vez que hizo algo parecido fue en 1986
para asistir a la boda del príncipe
Andreu con Sara Duquesa de York pero
ahora en su tienda de campaña frente al
buckingham Palace rodeada de banderas o
fotos y figuras de la corona espera por
algo mucho más grande Estoy feliz por
estar aquí y formar parte de la historia
no había pasado algo parecido en 70 años
como ellas a miles de Seguidores de la
realeza británica esperan vivir el
cuento de hadas frente al palacio cuando
los reyes crucen con su carroza
acompañados Por un desfile de 5000
miembros de las fuerzas armadas